alien prequel alien so alien covenants
directed by Ridley Scott it's a
Prometheus sequel or an alien break oil
if you look at the poster is what we
wanted in Prometheus pretty much this
movie takes place after Prometheus and
instead of Prometheus worth like oats
science expedition this is sort of a
colony mission however they hear a
signal from this other planet so they go
to investigate that we have an alien
prequel first of all brutally Scott I
want to get the obvious over whether
movie looks great it's so beautiful of
course it does it's already Scott felt
anyone it's like the movie like Takei
but yeah no
is the movie good itself that's the
variable and now like before there are a
lot of big prophecy grand world there's
not a lot happening in the world until
they arrive there is wheat that's there
just looking at the landscape and scope
though you're like this is really Scott
because that's right
it looks great there's really being an
alien prequel and a Prometheus sequel it
does still hold to the fact that these
people are the dumbest people when it
comes to protocol ever ever in all of
the movies really you look at it you
guys make dumb calls when dangerous
shits happening the pilot the crew in
this movie no exception really however
this movie is some good visual horror
you saw in the trailers as aliens
busting out of this dudes back of like
that Brava but it was super like
horrifically gory which it was like
science gory which is the best kind of
gory ever it's like if you're going to
be gory be science story it's almost
like it's fringe it's real there are
parasites out there that actually lay
eggs and animals and they bust out of
them it's scary I'm really primal
about that so then when you have these
little things coming after they're out
not only was that scary but now here we
are with alien ish movies then you start
getting the alien that the poster
and the trailers are pitching you
however I will say is that part of it
which is really the part I came to see
happen is about the last third of the
movie before that it's a lot like for me
theaters like ooh crazy thing let's go
investigate let's go explore science II
things and more exploring and more
questions and it was really cool because
I like seeing the extension of the
Prometheus sequel and a movie actually
all things considered does it really
well Michael Fassbender is in the movie
again playing a different Android well
actually he does play David and new
Android with southern accent his name
I can't remember because I'm with
name is it I think is Walter if I had a
robot I would name it Walter
so if Walter became self-aware destroyed
the human race to be like the human race
was killed by Walter Brad is that but
facts bender really does carry I mean
he's a really interesting dynamic
especially playing a dual role
Fassbender gives this movie the depth
that you want from a movie like this in
this day and age there is an element to
this movie where it more or less has a
jump and so you don't see the Prometheus
path like Prometheus ends like we got to
go here and do that thing that thing
really isn't the point of this movie so
in that I feel like there's a huge
section of story that's just missing
granite is missing for the sake of
intrigue but it is missing I don't know
I feel like it's on the cutting room
floor somewhere I mean the crew stands
out too I mean it had a good cast
granted a lot of the crews like these
are expendable people it's going to
start out with a handful of people maybe
a pinch they're going to be the ones
that concentrates on everyone else like
you're going to die somehow probably
horrible does because in the end alien
covenant is an enjoyable sci-fi I
thought it was better than prometheus
personally however it comes down to what
you came to this movie for determine how
satisfied you are walking out of the
movie and really more or less if you
came here for the Prometheus sequel
you're not going to have all your
fulfillment if you came here for the
alien prequel okay and you're not going
to have all your book Velma because that
really is the last third of the movie
however it's what the movie ends with so
that's the last case you have in your
mouth and that it is more fulfilling I
walked out enjoying myself pretty
satisfied I will say alien covenant is a
good time no alcohol required alright
guys I'll ask you what's your favorite
sci-fi thriller horror whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]